[Musique]
caution patron de stocks d'abris bus un
merci nounours il y à un tel brouillard
ce soir que j'ai bien cru que nous ne
retrouverions jamais la rue des enfants
sages recevoir mes petits amis pour le
seul propos il est bien pressé d'aller
jouer ce soir notre nounours au soir des
chérubins mes petits chérubins jolie
voyons on ne dit pas bon soir à son
nounours ce soit nous voyons ça n'ont
alors plus petit chérubin
on s'arrête à chérubins je m'appelle
nicolas et moi patronne elle et toi tu
t'appelles nonick tu t'appelles pas cher
boudin on te dit pas bonjour chers
boudin on te dit bonjour maintenant on
est pas mal à l'écran de toujours nous
appelait de nom comme ça moi j'en ai
marre que je suis peu que je peux
bonsoir propre gueule
bonsoir ni collant annonce
bonsoir et nicolas bideau bon voire à la
cuisine ya quelque chose pour toi sur la
table quelque chose tu ce moment alors
je veux ça c'est une bonne blague mais
c'est bien fait il n'avait qu'à pas nous
appeler chérubins au le content de
poireaux il n'y avait rien du tout sur
cette fin et puisque vous me faites de
ville une blague
moi je bombay je m'en vais je m'en vais
bien bonsoir
je le vois plus mon échelle c'est à
cause du gros da plus bas mon dieu vous
ne serez pas trop all hallow non aux
jardins ya les jeunes à des laits gels
des petits garnements
c'est vous qui me l'avait que vous allez
voir petits jobs n'avait coché le nom de
sean
la voile monnaie ma chère petite erreur
vous vous êtes bien moqué de moi ce soir
mais où vous bien qu'on ait nous aussi
on aime bien nos bonnes ni shereni
grands chais monnet bonne nuit petit
coquin l'ena j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
où
oh
pas trop je vous envoie mon échelle
[Musique]
ballons en route gros chérubin qui perd
son échelle oh non pas trop je m'appelle
mouddour alors en route nounours
bonne nuit des enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents faites votre toilette
n'oubliez surtout pas de vous laver les
dents et faites de beaux rêves
bonne nuit bolbec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]